good morning John I hope you don't mind
if me and nerdfighter area get together
and give you a little bit of an
intervention we are here for you and
your time of need but if you want to
continue having a loving and respectful
and kind relationship with all of us
you're gonna need to cut back on the
soccer if a person needs to create a
second Twitter account so they can tweet
more about the World Cup that person is
probably it's bending a little bit too
much time thinking about soccer I mean
it's great sure I don't want to argue
about whether or not soccer is really a
good game but no matter how good a game
it is John it's a game it might be a
great game but it is just a game and god
I just lost the game not the soccer game
but I though in my career as a
nine-year-old goalie I did lose my fair
share of those that has lost the game
you know the game the game and of course
now I have bad news for you and everyone
who's watching this you guys just lost
the game too so for the people who are
confused and somehow do not know that
they are currently playing the game let
me explain the rules
there is a game it is called the game
you are always playing it and there is
no way to win but if you think about the
game then you lose the game at first I
thought the game was really dumb saying
you just lost the game is a
self-fulfilling statement if you read
the statement then you have lost which
is kind of interesting I mean it's kind
of an interesting idea that there can be
a statement that fulfills itself but
mostly it's not interesting mostly it's
just annoying but over the years of
begrudgingly playing and losing and thus
thinking about the game I've come to
realize that the game is actually more
than a way for twelve-year-old boys to
exercise some tiny and meaningless
amount of power over other people really
fascinating thing about the game is that
the only way to win is to not know
you're playing unless I must apologize
the people who I just introduced the
concept of the game to but that idea
that you are always winning until you
know you're playing is actually a
fascinating bit of distilled wisdom
about the folly of humanity whereas the
internet troll may say the game you lost
it the truth of that statement is that
all desire and in some ways all
knowledge leads to loss it's strange
that one of the principal tenets of
Buddhism is hiding inside of an internet
meme but there you have it it's true of
every game and of everything if you play
you lose the only way not to lose is to
not know the game exists and the game is
everywhere I see it everywhere now take
an example of academic research
these are people who do a great deal of
good for the world they're very smart
people and their game the thing that
they are motivated by is being published
in academic journals that you have never
heard of and being recognized by
scientists that no one has ever heard of
they fight their entire professional
lives for that recognition and then when
they achieve it they only want more it
doesn't matter what game you're living
for if you're living for it you'll never
win the game can be anything it can be
the desire for fame or money or romantic
conquest and the game can even be desire
for good things like ending poverty or
having a really happy healthy family
recognizing this about the game that
we're all playing it and we're all
losing it has made me realize that
what's really important is that we're
playing the right game because you can't
win every marriage that doesn't end in
divorce ends in death
there's no way not to lose fights it
doesn't mean that there aren't fights
worth fighting but it does mean that
thinking that you only be happy when you
win is the surest way of never being
happy you just lost the game and you're
gonna spend the rest of your life losing
the game the only real way to win is to
not care if you lose and that is what I
got from spending way too much time
losing the game John I will see you on
Monday
you